is Jonathan Mages Kang from Marvel
really being used as a bit of a scap
goat welcome to SRE your SciFi TV and
Movie Channel so yesterday I did a video
talking about how within virtually
minutes of Jonathan major being found
guilty of the misdemeanor assault case
um Marvel basically let reporters know
that they would be cutting ties with the
actor this is thrown into question the
whole Kang Dynasty that was planned if
you're regular site track you'll know
that I've actually already talked about
this a little bit and actually said that
for one Loki season 2 was Rewritten to
allow for the Kang Dynasty to sort of
end there if needed and that actually
Avengers 5 which was slated in as being
Avengers 5 the Kang Dynasty is now
internally just being being called
Avengers 5 there is a writer the guy
actually that did Loki season 2 has come
in and is completely reworking the
script so it does look like if we see
Kang it will 100% well it won't be
Jonathan Mages but there is a
possibility we might see a CGI version
of Kang if they do decide to do
something and close off that
storyline but did they have to sack him
well for one he was only actually found
guilty of a misdemeanor this does mean
he could face a year in prison so it's
an old little thing but what he was
actually found guilty of was he had a
phone it a text came through and it
basically said I I wish I was kissing
you this isn't me by the way I didn't
text him another woman his girlfriend
saw this message went nuts grabbed his
phone he grabbed the phone back put her
arm up behind her back of p and smacked
her in the back of the head to you know
give me my phone back that is actually
what he was found guilty of there were
other things this does seem like it was
a very toxic
relationship and Marvel sacked him for
that now for one point he was found
guilty of a criminal act so most
contracts allow people to be fired if
you're found guilty in a court of law of
a violent um act I um in my real job if
I am found guilty of lots of different
crimes to be honest I could be fired for
it so on one respect it's not massively
shocking they hadn't out because legally
there'll be something in that contract
to say look if you put this in dis
disrepute or you get found guilty of a
criminal offense you can be released
from your contract you can be fired and
there's no recourse really for Jonathan
Majors there's nothing he can do about
it but did they have to well if you
consider Ezra Miller's case so from The
Flash he has had a lot of
very dodgy criminal stuff about him but
I have to say that a lot of it was
alleged because he was actually never
found guilty in the court of law for
most of it he was found guilty for a
trespass and something else um and he
had to promise to basically like do
anger management stuff and um Regular
drug testing and things so he was found
guilty though of That So in theory I
suspect Warner Brothers could use that
to fire him from The Flash and replace
him if they'd have wanted to I think the
flash was far enough along though that
it would have been insanely expensive to
do that and that's possibly one of the
reasons why they didn't don't forget
that if you like the video please hit
that thumbs up and leave a comment it
really helps with all those pesky
YouTube algorithms also subscribe like
and hit the Bell notification so you
never miss any of our new videos and I
do think that all of that stuff really
harmed the movie and caused a lot of
very negative publicity in the runup so
Marvel are obviously trying to avoid a
similar sort of thing but a lot of
Marvel films have not done very well in
the last few years and as I spoke to you
about in the last video they've been
trying to do a massive reset they've
been wanting to go a different direction
with Marvel and they have already
started to do that they've already
slowed down the calendar they're
reworking several of the TV and movie
projects are they using Jonathan M
criminal problem as an excuse to get rid
of him but more importantly is an excuse
to change the story line a story line
that isn't working because Disney don't
want to stand up and Marvel don't want
to stand up and go this isn't working
you people don't like this we're going
to do something else instead they can
stand up and say because of Jonathan
maor's criminal activities we have been
forced to change the storyline and this
is now what we're doing
it's less embarrassing for Mickey and
his friends I am wondering if that is at
least not part of the reason why
Jonathan mes was fired because as I said
he was only found guilty of a
misdemeanor as a maximum of one year in
prison speaking to a legal person I know
they've said the chances are he will not
go to prison um even though he didn't
actually say he was guilty if he'd have
actually said he was guilty at the start
of this court case it probably would
have ended very very quickly and the
chances are you have just got like
community service and maybe some anger
management I'm being told he'll probably
still will get that but he'll get more
of it so it's it's unlikely he's going
to go a prison according to my friend
who works in the legal area I will point
out that he's British is not an American
legal expert so it might be a little bit
different this same person though is the
one who said to me that look that's how
they got out of the contract he's
basically said there'll be something in
his contract about putting the Marvel
and Disney into disrepute so then get
rid of him that way but there's almost
certainly there's something about him
being found guilty of a crime I can't
help but feel though that if Marvel had
really wanted to they could have made
this go away Robert Downey Jr at the end
of the day was found guilty of several
crimes and he did go to prison but they
then hired him as Iron Man because he
was the right man and they knew he'd be
popular now I'm just saying here that I
think they could have spun this if
they'd have wanted to they could have
said yeah he's our Kang we want him to
continue this is um Jonathan mes he was
in a toxic relationship obviously things
went wrong but this isn't the person he
is he was provoked he's going to go to
anger management he's going to do this
he's going to do that we want him to
continue and people would have forgotten
about it but instead they've decided to
sack him immediately and I suspect that
is because at least in some level they
wanted to now is that because they just
wanted to change the storyline is that
because maybe they had issues with
Jonathan Mages themselves we will
probably never know for certain but it
does seem to me that him being done for
this misdemeanor assault is most
definitely convenient at very least for
lots of people over at Marvel and will
give them a really nice excuse for a
change in Direction
that has been forced on them really by a
bunch of movies that have been crap or
at the very least not well received at
the box
office but guys what do you think get
into the comments is this convenient for
Marvel and Disney or do you think really
they had no choice considering he was
found guilty of a physical assault
against a
woman I was always taught you don't hit
women however much you provoked so I
have to admit I look down on this and I
say this guy he did hit her in the back
of the head and that's not great and
he's been found guilty of that so I
don't have to say allegedly but what do
you think get to the comments if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification most
importantly so you never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com cidre where most of our new
videos Premiere first and you can go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do stories based on most of our
videos and we try to add a little bit
more more information for you to digest
go check it out as always please stay
safe I'll see you next
[Music]
time